I say we only use a fraction of our brain's true potential now that's when we're awake and we're asleep
Our mind can do almost anything
Such as imagine you're designing a building, right? You consciously create each aspect
But sometimes it feels like it's almost creating itself if you know what I mean
Yeah, like I'm discovering
Genuine inspiration, right?
Now in a dream, our mind continuously does this, we create and perceive our world simultaneously
And our mind does this so well that we don't even know what's happening
That allows us to get right in the middle of that process
How?
By taking over the creating part, now this is where I need you
You create the world of the dream
We bring the subject into that dream
And they feel it but they're subconscious
How could I ever acquire enough detail to make them think that it's reality?
Well dreams, they feel real while we're in them, right?
It's only when we wake up that we realize something was actually strange
Let me ask you a question
You never really remember the beginning of a dream, do you?
You always wind up right in the middle of what's going on
I guess, yeah
So how did we end up here?
Well, we just came from the...
Think about it, Ariadne, how did you get here?
Where are you right now?
What do you mean?
You're actually in the middle of the workshop right now, sleep in
This is your first lesson and share it with me, stay calm
Where are you going?
It's just a dream, the wire you just...
It's never just a dream, isn't it?
A face full of glass hurts like hell when you're in it
It feels real
It's why the military develops dream sharing
There's a training program for soldiers to shoot and stab and strangle each other and wake up
How did architects become involved?
Someone had to design the dreams, right?
Why don't you give us another five minutes?
Five minutes?
What?
We were talking for like at least an hour
And the dream, your mind functions more quickly, therefore
Time seems to feel more slow
Five minutes in the real world gives you an hour and the dream
Why don't you see what you can get up to in five minutes?
Five minutes in the real world